FOR COMING THIS AFTERNOON TO
OUR FIRST MEETING OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE- MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WALKING TO THE FIRST
POLICY HEARING. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU
TODAY. TODAY WERE ADOPTED THE
COMMITTEE ROLES AND HERE NINE
BILLS. THREE OF THOSE BILLS
WILL BE HEARD ON CONSENT. AS
YOU KNOW. DUE TO COVER NINETEEN
WE HAVE LIMITED ROOM AVAILABLE
FOR THE PUBLIC. IN THIS ROOM
AND IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX THE
CAPITAL. WHICH IS THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. PLEASE BE
MINDFUL OF THE MASS REQUIREMENT
FOR EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM AND A
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX AND
MAINTAIN PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
BY CALLING. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PIN NUMBER IS
ONE. THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN OR BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AT.
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. THAT'S
ESTABLISHES QUORUM WITH SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE.
RODRIGUEZ HERE HERE THERE ARE
STILL THERE YEAH. AGUIAR-CURRY
YEAH RIGHT CALDERON. GALLAGHER
RIGHT. FOR YOU'RE WORKING. IN
WHAT THAT WE HAVE A CORPSMAN.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
THE DAHLE OF THE ROLE IS THERE
A MOTION IN A SECOND. MOTION
AND A SECOND. OF A MOTION SIR
CIRCUIT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
GUESS HI RODRIGUEZ FIVE. THEY
ARE RIGHT THERE SO I AM VERY
VERY. I CALDERON. GALLAGHER
RIGHT. FOR WORD I'VE WITH THAT
THANK YOU IN THE RULES OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE ADOPTED NEXT
WE'LL CONSIDER THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS ARE ON CONSENT AB NINE
SEVEN THREE RODRIGUEZ AB TEN
SEVENTY ONE RODRIGUEZ IN A BE
FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE THE
COMMITTEE IS OUR MOTION AND
SECOND. THE MOTION AND A SECOND.
SO DO PASS THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I FIVE HI THERE
SO I GUARD THREE. OKAY VERY I'D
CALDERON. GALLAGHER OKAY FORD
FORD I'VE- IN THANK WITHOUT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS APPROVED
BEFORE WE CAN BEGIN WITH THE
BILL PRESENTATION ON TAKE A
MOMENT AND INVITE MEMBERS TO
MAKE AN OPENING COMMENTS TODAY
TODAY IS OUR FIRST COMMITTEE
FIRST TEARING THEM SAID TO BE
HERE WITH ALL OF YOU. SO
WITHOUT ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS BEFORE
PROCEED. SEEN NONE THEY WILL
CONTINUE I ALSO WANT TO THANK
AND RECOGNIZE THE HARD WORK OF
GETTING THIS COMMITTEE SET. SET
UP THANK YOU TO OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT MIKE TAKES IN DAYTON
ALSO THANK YOU DOORS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY TAYLOR GONZALEZ. SO
AT THAT I KNOW WE HAVE SENATOR
COME ALTER HERE TO PRESENT AB
ONE EIGHTEEN. SENATOR WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR DO YOU WANT ME HERE HERE
I THINK AT THE TABLE FOR. NICE
TO SEE A VERY. WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SO HAPPY TO SEE YOU ALL I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB ONE EIGHTEEN
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE
COMMUNITY RESPONSE INITIATIVE
TO STRENGTHEN EMERGENCY SYSTEMS
ALSO KNOWN AS THE CRISIS ACT
PILOT PROGRAM TO PROMOTE
COMMUNITY BASED RESPONSES TO
LOCAL EMERGENCY SITUATIONS. YOU
KNOW EVERY DAY IN COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE
SUCCESSFULLY RESPONDING TO
VARIOUS TYPES OF EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS. SUCH AS PEOPLE
DEALING WITH HOMELESSNESS
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS HAVING AN
EPISODE SOMEONE EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SOMEONE
DEALING WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
AB ONE EIGHTEEN IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF AB TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR FROM LAST SESSION
WHICH WAS PASSED. WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES NOT IN THE BILL ANALYSIS
THE BILL WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM STATING THAT THE
UNDERLYING GOAL OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS IMPORTANT. AND
IMPLEMENTING AN EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION WILL HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES UNFORTUNATELY- YES
IS NOT THE APPROPRIATE LOCATION
FOR THE PILOT PROGRAM PROPOSED
IN THIS LEGISLATION. MY
ADMINISTRATION WILL WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WHICH IS
THIS ONE ON AN IMPLEMENTABLE
SOLUTION SO MY OFFICE AND
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN
CORRESPONDING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- SINCE LAST
YEAR WE EVEN SPOKE TODAY TO
IDENTIFY THE APPROPRIATE STATE
AGENCY TO OVERSEE THE PILOT
PROGRAM. WE KNOW THE
INTERACTIONS WITH POLICE CAN BE
SCARY AND TRAUMATIZING FOR MANY
PEOPLE. AND OFTENTIMES THEY CAN
BE DEADLY IN FACT JUST LAST
WEEK THE SITE YES CERVANTES. A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD MAN WITH
AUTISM. WHO HAS THE MENTAL
ACUITY OF A SIX YEAR OLD AND IS
DEAF IN BOTH EARS. HAVE AN
EPISODE- BECAUSE HE WANTED A
SNACK. THE POLICE WERE CALLED.
I HE WAS SUBDUED IN HIS DINING
ROOM IN FRONT OF HIS MOTHER AND
SHOT IN THE BACK HE IS
CURRENTLY IN THE HOSPITAL AT
SAINT FRANCIS MEDICAL CENTER IN
LYNNWOOD. AND HE WILL BE
PARALYZED UNABLE TO WALK AGAIN.
BECAUSE HE WAS STAFF IS DEAF.
AND AUTISTIC. ALMOND HAVING
SOMEONE COME IN TO RESPOND. TO
HIM NOT WANTING A SNACK WITHOUT.
THE KIND OF COMPASSION BUT ALSO
RESPONSIVENESS TO TRAINING OUR
RESULTED- IN HIS SPINAL CORD
INJURIES. WE KNOW THAT IN
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ARE
RESPONDING SUCCESSFULLY TO
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS INVOLVING
ON HOUSE PEOPLE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES PEOPLE EXPOSED TO
VIOLENCE AND PEOPLE IMPACTED BY
NATURAL OR CLIMATE DISASTERS.
IN L. A. FOR EXAMPLE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE SECOND CALL
IN MUSTARD SEED INTERVENE TO
BUILD PEACE FATHERS AND
FAMILIES OF SAN JOAQUIN WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE CITY TO ENSURE
ITS MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
ARE SHELTERED WE KNOW BERKELEY
FROM FREE CLINIC PROVIDES
HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE AND HOUSED. AND SUFFER
FROM SUBSTANCE ABUSE. WHEN
THESE GROUPS ARE RESOURCE TO DO
THIS CRITICAL WORK ALL OF US
BENEFIT AND WE ALSO SAVE-
DESPITE THE POSITIVE IMPACT AND
COST SAVING POSSIBILITIES OF
COMMUNITY ORIENTED RESPONSES TO
EMERGENCIES CALIFORNIA HAS DONE
LITTLE. TO SUPPORT AND SCALE
THESE EFFORTS OR TO SET
STATEWIDE POLICY FOR GUIDANCE
SO INSTEAD LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
CONTINUING. TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES BETTER SUITED TO
PEER SUPPORT EXPERTS MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS OR CRISIS
COUNSELORS TRYING TO DE
ESCALATE AND RESOLVE CRISES.
THERE IS ALSO A COST SAVINGS
BENEFITS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I LOVE
TALKING ABOUT MONEY IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WORKERS COMP COSTS FOR
SWORN EMPLOYEES WERE A HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE L. A.
FIRE DEPARTMENT WAS SPENDING
ALMOST TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR ON OVERTIME JUST TO COVER
SHIFTS LEFT VACANT BY INJURED
FIREFIGHTERS. AND ACCORDING TO
THE L. A. CONTROLLER ONE IN
THREE LAPD OFFICERS FILED A
WORKERS OMP CLAIM COSTING
NEARLY NEARLY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. AND LEAVING 15%
OF THE DEPARTMENTS HUMAN
RESOURCES ON THE SIDELINES. WE
KNOW THAT ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS WAS SPENT NATIONWIDE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT JUST FOR
TRANSPORTING PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND THESE NUMBERS GO
UP EVERY YEAR. WE KNOW THESE
JOBS ARE STRESSFUL WE KNOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS OVERWHELMED
OVERWORKED BURNED OUT. AND WE
KNOW THAT OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
ARE BEING ASKED TO. MORE AND
MORE RESPOND TO THESE
SITUATIONS WHERE MAYBE THEY'RE
NOT NEEDED OR THEY'RE NOT
NEEDED FIRST. AB ONE EIGHTEEN
IS NOT ABOUT REPLACING THIS
IMPORTANT AND EXISTING
WORKFORCE BUT A BOUT EXPANDING
THE ROLE OF COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
THAT HAVE DEMONSTRATED THEY CAN
PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITIES WERE
OFFERING LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
FOCUS ON ISSUES MORE SUITED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING. SO
WITH ME TODAY AND SUPPORTER
SHARON WATKINS WAS SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG ANA SANTA BOB
WAKEN FOUNDEROF MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST SACRAMENTO MOVE THE BILL.
SECOND HAS MOTION SECOND SO YOU
DO HAVE TO WITNESSES TESTIFYING
BY PHONE CORRECT CORRECT ALL
RIGHT. FIRSTOPERATOR DO YOU
HAVE THOSE WITNESSES TESTING BY
PHONE READY TO TESTIFY. YES
BOTH WITNESSES ARE HAVE OPEN
LINES AND MAY BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE IN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SHERIN MARC AND I AM A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER OF THE
SILICON VALLEY DE. ACROSS
MONSTER MONSTER OF ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE EIGHTEEN. MY STORY
BACK TO FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AT APPROXIMATELY FIVE
IN THE EVENING WHEN MY SON
PHILLIP WATKINS WAS SHOT AND
KILLED BY SOME OF THE POLICE
OFFICERS DURING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. I WOULD A PHONE CALL
FROM MY SON AND SAY TELL ME
THAT MY TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD
SON WAS TALKING ABOUT KILLING
HIMSELF. YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
SHOCK AND HORROR I FELT WE SEE
THE NEXT PHONE CALL IF I HAD
NEVER EXPERIENCED ANYTHING LIKE
THIS WITH HIM BEFORE AT ANY
TIME OF THE FLIGHT. I
IMMEDIATELY RUSHED FROM WORK TO
TRY SEE HIM. WITH HIS FIANCEE
CALLED AGAIN. THIS TIME THERE
WERE CUT MY VERY SOUL. FISH OUT
OF UP HERE AND THEY SHALL NOT.
I WOULD CONFUSE WHAT HAPPENED
WHAT IF KILLED ONE OF I MET.
THE WASN'T UNTIL THE THAT. THAT
MIGHT FIANCE HER MOTHER FILLED
ME IN ON THE DETAILS. THEY WERE
PLEADING THE OFFICER MATHIS YOU.
SHOUTING AT SCREAMING HE NEEDS
YOU NEED HELP DON'T SHOOT HIM
HELP. IT GET THAT HELPED.
ESTABLISH A IN TIME WHILE THE
ONE HALF YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
WITHIN A NEAR. THE OFFICERS ON
THE SCENE THAT THEY WERE NOT
THERE TREAT NEXT. THEY WERE NOT
THERE TO MAKE SURE MY- THROUGH
THIS TOUGH TIME HIS WIFE. TO
MAKE SURE YOU GET THE HELP YOU
NEED IT. WHAT MY FAMILY THAT
THAT THEY WILL NOT BE MET BY
ARMED POLICE. MY SON NEEDED
WITH TRAINS HERE SUPPORT.
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS OF
CRISIS COUNSELORS ARE SKILLED
IN ESCALATION AND PROVIDING
CARE. A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
SHOULD NOT WARRANT A DEATH
SENTENCE. I'M HERE TO URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT AB ONE EIGHTEEN. IT
WILL GIVE MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT
TO COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
TREAT THOSE EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. LIKE THE
ONE MY SON EXPERIENCE. WITH
CARE COMPASSION AND KNOWLEDGE
OVER THE- THERE IS A BETTER WAY
THANK YOU BANK FOR. ARE VERY
TOOK TO RESPOND TO LOCAL
EMERGENCY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS
TESTIFYING BY PHONE GOING YOU
READY. HELLO MY NAME IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT CAN AND FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
COME ALIVE OR DEAD AND HER
STAFF WERE STANDING BEHIND AB
ONE EIGHTEEN FOR STANDING UP
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE MH FARMS AND
FOR LISTENING TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND PUTTING FORTH
LEGISLATION. THAT CAN CHANGE IN
THEIR LIVES. AGAIN MY NAME IS A
TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU AND I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND ALSO THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR MENTAL
HEALTH BIRD. DIVERSE VIDEO AB
ONE EIGHTEEN A LOT OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. FROM ALL
SECTORS TO SCALE LET THE
BROADLY AND CONTINUE TO CREATE
THE TYPE OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SYSTEM. THAT HELP OUR FRIENDS.
THAT HELP OUR FAMILY MEMBERS
AND OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS
WELL. AB ONE EIGHTEEN WILL
ENCOMPASS EVERYTHING FROM
NATURAL TECHNOLOGICAL OR MAN
MADE DISASTERS. TO HELP
PRACTICES. INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE COMMUNITY VIOLENCE AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. OUR
COMMUNITY NEEDS THAT. EVOLUTION
WE HEAR ABOUT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
SAYING WHY THEY CAN'T OR WON'T
CALL NINE ONE ONE. SOMETIMES
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD A
BIRTH EXPERIENCES THERE HAVE
BEEN HARMED BY OFFICES. OTHER
TIMES THAT WOULD TAKE A LEFT
THAT. SENT THEM MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO CALL.
PAUL WHO ARE ARE. OTHERS ARE
DEALING WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AND NEED ACCESS TO THE
TYPE OF CARE THAT DOES NOT FIX
THAT WOULD BE FOR THEM TO BE
CLEANED IN ORDER TO GET BACK
HERE. ON JANUARY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND EIGHTY PP
DECIDED TO STOP WAITING AS MANY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS HAVE.
AND BEGAN TO CREATE THE SUSPEND
OUR COMMUNITY NEEDED WE HAVE
SENT TO SPEND IT TO A MAGICIAN
OF THE BEGIN HAVING FIRED
SEVERAL OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO CREATE
THEIR OWN PROGRAM. IMAGINE HOW
AB ONE EIGHTEEN CANNON WILL
EXPAND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ALREADY HAVE
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT. AND THE
LIVED EXPERIENCE OF BUILDING
SYSTEMS BUT ONLY LACK THE
RESOURCES. OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS
TO BE AN EXAMPLE IN THE SAME
WAY THEY COME WATER THAT HAVE
BEEN LISTENING TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. LISTEN TO THE
ONCE YOU HAVE THE LOS VOICES
THE LAW IS RESPECTED. YOU AND
ALTERNATIVE. SYSTEM WITHOUT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY ELSE
PART VIA FOR OF AB. ONE
EIGHTEEN. HEARING NONE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT VIA. THE CONFERENCE
ROOM OR HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SOON HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION VIA
PHONE. TO AB. ONE EIGHTEEN.
OPERATOR ONE AND ONE ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU MR- ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR SHORT NEED TO USE
AT THIS POINT OR FULL WITNESSES
STATEMENTS. YOU DO ME TOO THAT
HAVE THOSE. OKAY I HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE IN QUEUE AT THIS TME AS
A REMINDER FOR OTHERS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO. STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
AB ONE EIGHTEEN UNION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. IF THIS IS NOT THE
BILL YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO YOU
MAY REPEAT THE COMMAND TO
REMOVE YOURSELF. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS FOUR ONE THEN ZERO FOR AB
ONE ONE EIGHT. FOR THE FIRST
TIME LINE SIXTY TWO SIX TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD ACTORS
AFTERNOON CARE NUMBERS
CREDIBILITY DOES ON BEHALF OF
SEVERAL- CLIENTS- CALIFORNIA
STATE PHYSICIAN A PSYCHIATRIST
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
OUR NEXT NEXT TO THE- NEXT IN
LINE FORTY YES WE HAVE MANY IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. FOUR ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MALIK BYNUM WITH UW ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
REPRESENTING OVER I DIDN'T
FORTY THOUSAND ACCESS PROVIDERS
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE HERE AS CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND WE
STRONGLY. SUPPORT NEXT DEADLINE
SIXTY THREE IN SIX THREE YEAR
LINES OPEN. MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE EIGHTEEN. LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. H. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE GIFFORDS
LAW CENTER IN SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH. PINE SIXTEEN ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON
THIS IS MOLLY WROTE SAN WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATE
THE CALIFORNIA IN PART. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY ONE
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KAELIN DEAN
FROM THE EASTER YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTION PRACTICAL FUNCTION IN
THE BILL I'M ALSO READING ON
BEHALF OF OPEN POWER PROJECTS
PROPOSED SPONSOR AND INITIATE
JUSTICE PROUD SUPPORTER OF THE
BILL. LINE FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ALEC
KESSLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPSAND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE EIGHTEEN. NINE FORTY
NINE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SACRAMENTO CAN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ACCESS TO PRODUCTIVE
JEFF CRACKLED BONSER OF AB ONE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ALLEY- WITH
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION IN
THE CALIFORNIA STOP. BOB
BONDURANT OF THE BILL AND URGED
FOR YES- THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
NINE THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FLAPPING IN THE CURRENT
EDITORIAL CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ME TOO SURVIVORS MARCH
INTERNATIONAL AN ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS THAT ADVOCATES FOR
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND WE ARE
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB ONE
EIGHTEEN. FOUR NINE TWELVE ONE
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JONATHAN MARLEY CALL ON
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY WORKERS AT THE
BERKELEY FREE CLINIC PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF AB ONE ONE EIGHT
AND WE'RE- RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT. BERMAN ONLINE
TWENTY NINE TO NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOHN VASQUEZ CALLING
ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB ONE
EIGHTEEN. AM PLEASED. WHAT THE
BILL THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND
THANK YOU THIS IS REBECCA GREEN
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF BEND
THE ARC JEWISH ACTION
CALIFORNIA WE'RE ALSO PROUD
SUPPORTERS OF AB. ONE EIGHTEEN.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY ONE
SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS KELLY SPECTER ON THE
LOS ANGELES RESIDENT AND PARENT
OF A DISABLED CHILD AND I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO SUPPORT AB. ONE
EIGHTEEN. WINE FORTY EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE MIDDLE TOP THE
END WITH THESE JUSTICE CALLS
WITHIN AND SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES PROUD COSPONSORED.
ASKING FOR A YES VOTE THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ERIC WANTS THEM MASON
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF PAUL
MIKE BE A LIFE THE- WE'RE COKE
FONG AB ONE EIGHTEEN AND OUR
STOCK FOR THE BILL. THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME. NINE FORTY SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MY NAME IS ON A JACKSON-
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ORGANIZERS IN THE SOLIDARITY
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB ONE
EIGHTEEN. RESPECTFULLY URGE
THAT YOU PASS THIS BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TOP. LINE FORTY
ONE FOR WALKING PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY LINE FORTY ONE DID
YOU WANT TO SHARE YOUR POSITION.
I MOVED TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ADELINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO ONE. YEAH YES THE
STATE YOUR POSITION. EIGHTY
MATHEMATICALLY BARA AND I AM
WITH THE AMERICAN INDIAN
MOVEMENT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THE AB ONE EIGHTEEN AND WE ARE
ASKING FOR THE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT IN LINE
SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
VICTORIA ROME WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
FOUR TO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BECKY
COFFIELD SHAMAN. UP MY DAUGHTER
DIANA SHAMAN WITH BLASTS POLICE
VIOLENCE IN. TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I REMEMBER AS SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG IN LEARN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AB ONE EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU. BLIND FIFTY FOUR
FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS ROSY TRAVIS I'VE
ALSO LOST A LOVED ONE TO POLICE
VIOLENCE AND WOMEN ORGANIZER
THE HELICON PEOPLE. WAS A PROUD
CO SPONSOR AB ONE EIGHTEEN ON
BEHALF OF OUR FAMILIES WHO'VE
LOST LOVED ONES TO QUICKLY
CLIMATE. AND WE URGE THE YES SO
IT ON AB ONE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
WELL I AM SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS THIS
IS DEANGELO MATCHED WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES- BUT A CO
SPONSOR VERY PROUD CO SPONSOR.
AB ONE EIGHTEEN I AM IN GREAT
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NINE SEVENTY THREE SEVEN THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DONNA MUNSON ARTICLE
CATTLE AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ROOM SINCE AMAT
DO NOT START A WHOLE NEW
PEOPLE- AND WE ARE URGING THAT
YOU SUPPORT AB ONE EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU. WELL I AM THIRTY
THREE THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MAXINE GELD
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CENTER FOR JUSTICE PROUD
SUPPORTERS OF AB. ONE EIGHTEEN.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU
THIS IS- TRACY ROSENBERG
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
PRIVACY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. ONE EIGHTEEN. WELL LINE
EIGHTY SIX EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN'T. OKAY WONDERFUL MY
NAME'S NOT YOU CAN'T YOU WITH
UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT
TIMELINE EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. BUT A
LINE TWENTY TWO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SHERRY
BARRON AND I'M FROM WHITE
PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES MATTER
LOS ANGELES PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
AB ONE EIGHTEEN CALLING FOR
SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JUDY
MARC- CALLING FROM DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED AND FROM THE SITE
OF A PROTEST ON BEHALF OF
JUSTICE FOR THE THREE YEAR
CONTRACT AND WE ARE A STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY AS AS AN AB ONE
EIGHTEEN SO THAT NOTHING LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU HE SAY AT
THIS WEEK I HAPPENED AGAIN AND
I HAVE ANOTHER PERSON FROM THE
PROJECT HERE WITHOUT THE ACT.
THE NUMBER OF BUT NOT THE
GOVERNMENT SO YOU'LL BUY THAT
AT THE MEET THE WINNING OPEN
DOWN SYNDROME DESPITE APT FOR
YOUR AB ONE ONE EIGHT YOU HAVE
MEANT THAT REPRESENT THOUGH I
LIKE WHEN THAT INTAKE THAT ACT.
IT TOOK ALMOST NEED BUT IT
CAN'T YOU HAVE GUESTS AND THAT
FOR YOUR THEY MIGHT LAKE YOU
SAY YES AB ONE OWNER. OR TO
PURCHASE. OUR FINAL KEY FROM MY
SIX EIGHT SIX EIGHT WITH DOOR.
MY NAME IS SHERRY SIMS ON THE
VALLEY DE BUG WHERE. SPONSOR
EIGHTY ONE EIGHTEEN WE URGE THE.
COOPER YOU HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
LINE VOTE. YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WELL. WE DO A LINE NINETY SIX
NINE SIX ZERO LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JAMES BIRCH OF
THE ANTI POLICE TERROR PROJECT
COOK BONTA IN SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU OPERATING GALLAGHER.
OKAY SO WITHOUT WILL MOVE IT TO
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
EIGHTEEN ANYONE ON THE PHONE
VIA OPPOSITION OPERATOR. IT WAS
STILL COMING IN OPPOSITION ONE
OF THEIR AT THE TIME. ONE
MOMENT. THE TO LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AND- HI THIS IS
SHEILA BATES WITH BLACK LIVES
MATTER LOS ANGELES BLACK LIVES
MATTER CALIFORNIA AND I AM
PROUD WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND WE URGE YOU TO
COURT AND- YEAH. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR IN ONE OUNCE SIX TO GO
TO LINE EIGHTY NINE. I NINE
MONTGOMERY HALF OF CALDERON
PROFIT THERE'S A CORD SB ONE
EIGHTEEN. OPERATORS OR ON
OPPOSITION DROWNED WHEN A SMALL
POSITION OR. AGAIN WE HAVE- YOU
WANT TO COME IN OPPOSITION
ARGUMENT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THERE IS NO COMMON THANK
YOU. OKAY WITH THAT SAID AS-
ONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE ROOM OR HEARING ROOM TO
AB ONE EIGHTEEN. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE OF BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- AB. ONE EIGHTEEN. SEEN
NONE I DO HAVE A I RECOMMEND
THIS THANK YOU CENTER FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL FORD LOOKING FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING IT. AND A WITHOUT
SECRETARY CAN CALDERON.
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ I SEE
OURSELVES NUMBER. SIR DO NOT
VOTING AYE GREGORY AYE GREGORY
AYE CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I GREAT
ALL RIGHT GREAT I WORD. BUT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO PREPARE
APPROPRIATIONS OKAY THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU CENTER THANKS
SHARE GOOD TO SEE EVERYONE
THANK YOU DON'T FORGET ABOUT US.
OKAY WITH THAT I THINK WE HAVE
A ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALIDATORS.
LIKE TO PRESENT ON AB. FOUR
EIGHTEEN. MOVE THE BILL. THERE
IS A MOTION ON SECOND. SO WITH
THAT GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
THANK YOU A CHAIR MEMBERS AND
TIME FOR WORKING WITH MEDIA
IMPROVE THIS BILL AND FOR YOUR
AMENDMENTS THAT WE DID ACCEPT
AB FOURTEEN IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT WILL FORMALLY
ESTABLISHED THE COMMUNITY POWER
RESILIENCY PROGRAM ALLOWING
HOW- YES TO DISPERSE GRANTS TO
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PREPARE.
FOR AND MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF OR
PS PS EVENTS- OR OTHER
EMERGENCY POWER OUTAGES TODAY
THERE'S NO QUESTION AS TO HOW
DEVASTATING THE LOSS OF POWER
CAN BE TO COMMUNITIES NOW MORE
THAN EVER CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
RELY ON RELIABLE ENERGY TO MAKE
A LIVING TO GO TO SCHOOL TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE. AND TO
ACCESS ESSENTIAL SERVICES I'M
DURING THIS PANDEMIC IN MY
COMMUNITY WE HAD SEVERAL POWER
OUTAGES PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
OUTAGES AND WHEN KIDS ARE
TRYING TO GO TO SCHOOL VIA ZERO
WHEN YOU HAVE NO POWER AND NO
ACCESS TO INTERNET. OR WHEN
YOUR REFRIGERATOR ISN'T WORKING
BECAUSE THERE'S NO POWER AND
YOU NEED I'M TO KEEP YOUR
INSULIN REFRIGERATED-
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN THIS
PANDEMIC AT HOME WITH NO POWER
ARE BEING DEVASTATED AND SEWER
COMMUNITIES AND SO OUR CITIES
OR OUR SPECIAL DISTRICTS. FOUND
THERE WAS A FACEBOOK VIDEO IN
MY DISTRICT OF A DARK
INTERSECTION AND THEN THE STARK
INTERSECTION THIS DAD PULLED
OVER BECAUSE IT WAS FIVE
O'CLOCK IN I THINK IT WAS
ACTUALLY FOUR THIRTY ASH. AND
IT WAS DARK AND IN THE
INTERSECTION SIX CARS BLEW
PAST- WHAT IS NORMALLY A RED
STOP LIGHT AND THE LAST CAR IT
ANOTHER CAR- ARE CITIES IN NEED
A RESOURCES A NEED FLEXIBILITY-
AND ACCESS TO GRANTS THAT HELLO
YES HAS PROVIDED OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS BECAUSE THE STATE AND
FREQUENCY EXPERIENCES BECAUSE
THE STATE FREQUENTLY
EXPERIENCES COMPLEX AND OFTEN
OVERWHELMING DISASTERS. SUCH AS
WILDFIRES FLOODS. MUDSLIDES
EARTHQUAKES DOWN I'M FAILURE.
AND GASLY. PS PS AND UNPLANNED
EMERGENCY OUTAGES HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME THE NEW
NORMAL FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING THE MAJORITY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS. THOUGH THE STATE
HAS ALLOCATED SOME GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THESE FUNDS
BARELY SCRATCHED THE SURFACE
SURFACE OF WHAT IS NEEDED. AND
WERE NOT SUFFICIENTLY FLEXIBLE
OR TRANSPARENT. AB FOUR
EIGHTEEN WILL FORMALLY
ESTABLISH A MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
STREAM. FOR REQUIRE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THEIR
DISTRIBUTION. BY DOING SO THIS
BILL WILL HELP CITIES COUNTIES
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND TRIBES
ENSURE THE CONTINUITY. OF THE
CRITICAL SERVICES FOR THE
RESIDENTS DURING PS PS EVENTS
OR OTHER EMERGENCY POWER
OUTAGES. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL OR JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
AND MAYOR PRO TEM OF THE CITY
OF SANTA CLARITA LORING WEST.
WITHOUT THE ABILITY BOTH
WITNESSES TESTIFYING VIA PHONE
SEPARATOR CAN YOU ARGUMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI CAN YU ALL
HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN KENNEDY
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTEEN ON BEHALF
OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE IN A SITUATION OF THIRTY
SEVEN WORLD COUNTY AND ARE
COUNTY SUSCEPTIBLE LONG TERM
DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES OVER THE
PAST DECADE AND- HAVE ALSO
EXPERIENCED MOST OF THE STATE'S
PS PS ABOUT. SOME OF THOSE
HARDEST HIT INCLUDE PEW
MENDOCINO NAPA NEVADA PLUMAS
SHASTA CINNAMON TAMA COUNTY AND
A NUMBER AND SEVEN CALIFORNIANS
WELL. AB FOUR EIGHTEEN AS SAID
SIX TO CODIFY A COMMUNITY POWER
RESILIENCY PROGRAM MODELED
AFTER THE EXISTING GRANT
ALLOCATIONS BY- YEAH US. WE
APPRECIATE THE ALLOCATION OF
GRANT FUNDING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND THE
SIGNIFICANT STATE COMMITMENT
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS TO
ADDRESS UNANTICIPATED PS PS
RELATED COSTS MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABUSE THESE
RESOURCES TO PROCURE BACKUP
POWER SUPPLIES FOR CRITICAL
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND ALSO TO SUPPORT FIRST
RESPONDERS IN OTHER CASES THE
FUNDS ARE USED TO PRE INSTALL
ELECTRICAL UPGRADES NECESSARY
TO SUPPORT MOBILE GENERATORS
DURING THE PS PS EVENT OR OTHER
EMERGENCY. WE SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTEEN THE EFFORTS TO
CODIFY THIS PROGRAM AND THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
BEING ADOPTED TO BROADEN LOCAL
DISCRETION AS TO HOW THEY
SHOULD BE USED. WELL WE SUPPORT
INITIAL FUNDING TO HELP
COMMUNITIES COPE WITH PS PS
EVENTS AND OTHER- POWER OUTAGES
OUR OVERARCHING GOAL IS THE
UTILITIES WILL SOON NO LONGER
NEED TO CALL THIS OFFENSE. BUT
I THINK WE'RE STILL SEVERAL
YEARS AWAY FROM THAT AND THEIR
SIGNIFICANT ON THAT LOCAL NEED
TO IMPROVE LOCAL RESILIENCE. SO
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. FOR EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN. OKAY OKAY OPERATORS
OF SOMEONE ELSE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR RIGHT. VICE CHAIR C. R.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AND MAYOR PRO TEM OF THE RAIN
LAST FROM THE CITY OF SANTA
CLARITA AND I AM HONORED TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CRUZ CITY COUNCIL TO
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL. FOUR EIGHTEEN. FORMALLY
ESTABLISHING THE COMMUNITY
POWER RESILIENCE PROGRAM IS
CRITICAL IN ENSURING STATE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO PREPARE FOR AND MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF A POWER SHUT UP YOU
THAT. SANTA CLARITA HAS
EXPERIENCED SEVERAL POWER SHUT
OFF VALVES AT TIMES IT'S
IMPACTING OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS AND
BUSINESSES AT PERIODS OF OVER
TWENTY FOUR CONSECUTIVE HOURS
OF POWER LINE. TWO MAJOR AND
RECENT POWER SHOT OFF THE VANS
ECKERD IN OUR CITY ON DECEMBER
TWENTY THIRD AND TWENTY FOURTH.
THAT LEFT THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES
WITHOUT POWER AND MANY WITH
DAMAGE DEVICES OR FORCED TO
DISCARD PERISHABLE FOOD ITEMS
DURING A MAJOR HOLIDAY WEEK.
ADDITIONALLY THE EXTENDED POWER
OUTAGES HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED TRAFFIC SAFETY. ES DE
ENERGIZED EVENTS HAVE SURPASSED
EVEN THE CAPACITY OF BACKUP
GENERATORS TO SOME OF OUR
TRAFFIC INTERSECTIONS. IT IS
OUR HOPE THAT THE CITY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE THIS
PROGRAM TO RETROFIT OUR
COMMUNITY CENTERS AND LIBRARIES
TO BE USED AS A RESOURCE
CENTERS OR EXACT YOU ATION
SHELTER FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. INDIVIDUALS WITH
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS AND
GENERAL PUBLIC DURING. POWER
DISRUPTIONS ADDITIONAL LIFE THE
CITY WHAT PURCHASE AND INSTALL
TRAFFIC MITIGATION EQUIPMENT TO
TARGETED INTERSECTIONS THAT ARE
IN THE GREATEST NEED FOR BACKUP
BATTERY SUPPORT DURING A POWER
SHOT OUT TO VENT. AND LASTLY AS
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY BE
AMENDMENTS MADE TO THIS
LEGISLATION TO REFINE THE SCOPE
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ASSEMBLYWOMAN
VALLADARES AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN
ENSURING THE COMMUNITY POWER WE
SAID ON THE PROGRAM. IS
ULTIMATELY. CODIFIED IN STATUTE.
I TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR CAN. OF
MY COMMENTS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE SENATE CREATE A CITY
COUNCIL I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR FIVE VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT YOUR PHONE. IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT SUPPORT
YOU MAY HAVE ONE OF THEM AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS GO TO
LINE SEVENTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHT YEARS HAMBURG FAIRBRIDGE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHT P.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
MCP MARIN CLEAN ENERGY AT THE
PORT AS AMENDED WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR ON ALLOWING- CCA
ALSO. EXPECTED SPENDING THANKS
TO MUCH. WE GO TO NINE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS-
RICHARD BILLION ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN PORT THANK
YOU. BUT THE- NEXT LINE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ALEX
IS STILL HIGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT THAT THANK YOU. OPERATOR
ANYONE ELSE INTO ART ALMOND
BOARD. YEAH PRESS ONE AND THERE
AT THE TIME. HI THIS TIME THAN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WITHOUT WILL GO OVER
TO OUR HEARING ROOM HERE IN THE
ROOM ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
FOR A BI FOURTEEN. SENATE
HEARING NONE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO A BEFORE EIGHTEEN
VIA FONG. OPERATOR ANYONE BE A
FAULTY WHICH COMMENT. IT WAS TO
COME IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
FOUR ONE EIGHT IN A PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU OPERATOR MOVED INTO A
COMMITTEE ROOM ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. FOR EIGHTEEN.
SENATE HEARING ON BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMENTS. THREE NINE I DO HAVE
A IRAQ ON THIS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRING THIS
BILL FOR THE FOR TO SUPPORT IT
AS WELL SO THAT SECRETARY CAN
CALL THE ROLL. RODRIGUEZ I
RODRIGUEZ I TALKED UP FIVE THEY
ARE TO AYE I GUARD THREE FIVE
AYE GREGORY AYE CALDERON.
WALDRON I GALLAGHER. GREAT FIVE
GREAT I WORD. BUT THAT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY THE MOTION
THANK YOU. SO WITH THAT WE HOW
FAR NUMBER THREE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. SENT AB
EIGHT ZERO FIVE WHEN YOU'RE
READY. MOVE THE BILL. ARE THERE
IS A MOTION AND A SECOND SO AT
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER JORDAN IN
LIGHT OF THAT ENCOURAGEMENT I
WILL LACK CUT BACK MY- MITCHELL
I KNOW MAJORITY SWEET MR GRAMM
I REGRET. THAT BUT- AB EIGHT OH
FIVE IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORKER
SAFETY PPVS. RATHER THAN SOME
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT TOOLS WE
HAVE IN THE FIGHTING IT'S CO ED
ADEQUATE PPE IS FOR OUR
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
ARE IMPORTANT PART OF INFECTION
CONTROL POLICY- DURING THE
WHOLE STATE OF EMERGENCY THE
REPORT. LISTED IN THE MATERIALS
GIVEN TO THE COMMITTEE
PREVIOUSLY WILL BE REQUIRED
WEEKLY AND ALL OTHER TIMES
WOULD BE REQUIRED MONTHLY WITH
MEET TODAY ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF TAYLOR
JACKSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION. ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT COOPERATION GO AHEAD
AND OPEN UP FOR SUPPORT. IT WAS
TO COME IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO
GO TO LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
RECORD BUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION ALSO WISHING
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT. AT THE
TIME THERE NO OTHER COUNTRY ALL.
YES YOU'RE CALLING SUPPORT IN
THE LINE OF. MISTER TURN
MEMBERS AT THE TAYLOR JACKSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION WERE SPONSORING
EIGHTY EIGHT OH FIVE AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
CHAIR AND THAT THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION-
NURSES RESPECTFULLY AFTER AN
AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY EIGHT OH
FIVE. THANK YOU OPERATOR ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. AT A TIME THAN
OTHERS IN Q. WITH THAT ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB IT'LL FIVE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
SEEING HEARING NONE. AWARD
OPPOSITION OPERATORS AT ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT OH
FIVE YOUR PHONE. IT WAS TO COME
IN OPPOSITION A BABY AND ALL
FIVE. ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND AT THE TIME THERE'S NO ONE
IN Q. BY THROWING OPPOSITION
VIA PHONE ANYONE OPPOSITION
HERE AND HERE IN ROOM AB. EIGHT
OH FIVE. SAN HEARING NONE WILL
GO INTO COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMENTS QUESTIONS. SO
WITHOUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOOK
FOR SUPPORT HIS BILL- I DO HAVE
A OUR RECORDS WITH THE
SECRETARY CALDERON. THERE IS A
MOTION AND SECOND AS WELL.
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ I WORKED
UP BY THEIR TO I GUARD CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I CALDERON
CALDERON I GALLAGHER. GREAT
GREAT I FORD. BUT THAT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK EMISSIONS
UP THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. AND NOW WE MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B.
FOURTEEN OH THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. FROM. FOR SO WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AB FORTINO THREE WOULD PROVIDE
CLARITY AND REITERATE THE
ABILITY. FOR THE GOVERNOR TO
CALL A STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
LOCAL AGENCIES AUTHORITY TO
CLEAR LOCAL EMERGENCY OR FOR
PLANNED THE ENERGY EFFICIENT
EVENT. SUCH AS THE UTILITY
INITIATED POWER SHUT OFFS. THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY WILDFIRE
SEASONS HAVE BEEN THE MOST
DEVASTATING IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY INCLUDING THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PARADISE CAMPFIRE. THE
SINGLE DEADLIEST WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY WILDFIRE SEASON.
PRODUCING THE LARGEST WILDFIRE
IN CALIFORNIA'S MODERN HISTORY
INVESTIGATORS FOR CAL.
DETERMINATE THE CATALYST BEHIND
THE PARADISE CAMPFIRE WAS UNDER
MANAGED ELECTRICAL TRANSMISSION
LINES OWNED AND OPERATED BY P.
JEANNIE. AN EFFORT TO REDUCE
POTENTIAL LIABILITY DURING FIRE
SEASON PG&E EXECUTED SEVERAL
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
OR PS PS EVENTS THROUGHOUT
OCTOBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
WHAT RESULTED WAS A POORLY
PLANNED SERIES OF PS PS EVENTS
THAT AFFECTED MILLIONS OF
CUSTOMERS INCLUDING MYSELF. I
MANY MEMBERS IN FACT UNLESS
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO RESPOND TO
NUMEROUS PUBLIC SAFETY IMPACTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
CALIFORNIA URGENCY SERVICES ACT
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR TO
ISSUE A STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS TO ISSUE A
LOCAL EMERGENCY OF CONDITIONS
EXIST THAT THREATEN THE
PERSONAL SAFETY. OF
CALIFORNIANS AND PROPERTY. AB
FORTINO THREE WOULD ADD PLAN TO
DE ENERGIZE NATION EVENTS
INCLUDING PS PS EVENTS. THE
LIST OF CONDITIONS CONSTITUTING
A STATE OF EMERGENCY DECLARED
BY GOVERNOR OR A LOCAL
EMERGENCY DECLARED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THIS
CLARIFICATIONS HELPFUL TO
PROVIDE GREATER FLEXIBILITY TO
LOCAL AGENCIES. RESPONDED PS PS
EVENTS AND TO SEEK FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE. TO
RECOVER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. OKAY WITH THAT
THERE'S A MOTIONS ARE SECOND.
THERE IS A MOTION AND SECOND AS
OR ANYONE OPERATOR. CALLING IN
SUPPORT TO AB FORTINO. THREE HE
WAS TO COME IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO THREE. PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HELLO THIS IS
JOHN KENNEDY AGAIN WITH RC RC
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB
FORTINO THREE I'LL SAVE YOU-
REITERATING WHAT WE JUST SENT A
COUPLE MOMENTS AGO BUT NOTE
THAT WHILE THE NUMBER OF
RESIDENTS IN COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY PSPO POTENTIAL FELL
SHARPLY. FROM TWO MILLION
PEOPLE IN TWENTY NINETEEN LAST
YEAR'S EVENT STILL LEFT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME. AB FORTINO
THREE IS AN IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION OF PF PF THEM'S
QUALIFIED THE DEFENSE FOR LOCAL
FOR WHICH LOCAL EMERGENCIES CAN
BE DECLARED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA REGENCY SERVICES
ACT. THERE'S SEVERAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
CALLED PS PS EVENTS OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS INCLUDING
MENDOCINO MONTEREY NEVADA SANTA
CLARENCE NO MY COUNTIES TO NAME
A FEW. AND AS THE AUTHOR STATED
THIS EQUIVOCATION IS REALLY
HELPFUL- BOTH PROVIDE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY TO OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES AND TO HELP US SEEK
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT TO RECOVER ALL OF THE X. A
SIGNIFICANT COSTS. THAT WE BEAR
RESPONDING TO THESE ACTIVITIES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OFTEN HAVE
LIMITED RESOURCES- AND THESE P.
FPS EVENTS OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS HAVE IMPOSED REALLY
SIGNIFICANT UNEXPECTED COSTS IN
TERMS OF LABOR OVERTIME.
CHECKING ON MEDICALLY SENSITIVE
RESIDENTS AND PROCURING BACKUP
GENERATORS SO WE SUPPORT IT AB
FORTINO THREE IS A COMMONSENSE
CLARIFICATION. AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. OKAY WITH THAT
OPERATOR ANYONE ELSE SINCE- TO
GO TO LINE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
TURNED IN SUPPORT. AT THE TIME
THAT SOMEONE ELSE THANK YOU.
OKAY WITH THAT ANYONE IN
SUPPORT TO AB FORTINO THREE
REAR HEARING ROOM. COMMITTEE
ROOM. SENATE HEARING ON ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION VIA PHONE TO AB
FORTINO THREE. OPERATOR ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE. YES JUST A MOMENT.
OKAY FIRST FIGURE TO LINE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THAT
ACT MEMBERS PHYSICALLY NOT
UNDERSTANDING OF GAS ELECTRIC
AND WE ARE CLOSED AND OPEN
ENDED BIGOTRY SHAPE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IN THE
AUTHORS AFTER MEETING WITH THE
OTHER CONCERN- AS WELL STATED
IN OF THE TO HELP LOCAL GUY FOR
COST RECOVERY PURPOSES THEN WE
CAN DISAGREE WITH THAT HOWEVER.
WE BELIEVE THAT. THE WAY THAT
IT CURRENTLY. IT WOULD AN
INTENTIONAL TRIGGER THE P. P.
TO NINE. DE THERE DASH TWO
FOUR. WHICH PROVIDE TWELVE
MONTHS OF RELIEF THAT. ADVANCED
INTENDED FOR K. EVENTS WITH
TERM IMPACT NOT APPROACH. FOR
EVERY GET THE AND WE WILL OFFER
LIKE TO KNOW THAT THERE IS AT
FIFTY ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
AND THAT WILL TO DO THE SAME
AND HELP LOCAL GUY AND ACT THAT
FUNDING TO COVER. AT THERE ARE
SEVERAL THINK THAT HAVE COME A
PUMP THE GREEN THE NEXT FIFTY
TWO AND FOR FOUR THREE TODAY.
ABOUT LIKE TAKING WORKING THE
AUTHOR AND CAN GET AWAY. WITH
THE EVER THAT ARE IN THE SENATE
SIDE- HAPPY TO. WORK BUT THERE
CAN BE ISLAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR
ANYONE ELSE. TO GO TO FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE LAURA SEVEN CASH AT A FAN
AND WE CANNOT A CURRENTLY ON
THE BELL WE WANT TO THINK
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF THAT
WORKING WITH A TO A SOME OF OUR-
BUT WE ALSO DON'T HAVE A
POSITION IN THAT. CLASS THE
BROAD STATED. AFFECTION OF THE
THAT WE HOPE WE CAN ADDRESS ANY
FURTHER COMPLICATE- BUT THE
AUTHOR- THE WITH THAT. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR AND ANOTHER ONE I
THINK YOU. NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU OKAY. SO WITHOUT OR BRING
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM FOR
HEARING ROOM ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO A BE FORTINO
THREE. SEMINARY NONE. OF BRING
IT TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANNE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SWEAT THAT
I BELIEVE THERE WAS A MOTION
AND SECOND I BELIEVE SO AND
THIS AND THANK OTHER MEMBERS
FROM THE SPORT SO WITHOUT
SECRETARY CAN CALL THE ROLL.
YES HI RODRIGUEZ. WORKED UP HI
THERE TILL I AYE GUARD CURRY.
AYE GREGORY AYE CALLED.
CALDERON I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
I'D GREAT. WARD. THE THOUGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ALL RIGHT THE
MOTIONS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS. AND WITH
THAT MOVE ON TO FAR NUMBER FIVE
A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY. FOR
GABRIEL. WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERRY
MEMBERS AND- I WILL BE BRIEF
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THIS WAS A
PROPOSED CONSENT ITEM. BUT I
WANT TO FIRST THANK THE TURN
THE STAFF FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO
BROADEN THE BILL TO MAKE IT
MORE BROADLY APPLICABLE. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE THE
COMMITTEE MEMINTA TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
HELP SUPPORT. LARGE TOURISM
EVENTS ACROSS THE STATE THIS IS
A BILL. THAT WAS PRIMARILY
DRAFTED IN IN PART TO TRY AND
ENCOURAGE. THE A WORLD CUP
FINAL TO BE PLAYED HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND TO-
MODELED AFTER BILL THAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE PAST AROUND THE
OLYMPICS. HOW TO TRY TO HELP
INSURE THAT THERE IS GOOD LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL COURT
NATIONAL SECURITY EVENTS WE
WANT TO BROADEN THAT NOW TO.
ADD THINGS LIKE THE SUPERBOWL
AND OTHER LARGE SCALE EVENTS
THAT- WILL PROMOTE TOURISM HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
THINK WE HAVE A LOT TO OFFER
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND WITH THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THAT WOULD BE UP. THANK
YOU TO HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND. I'LL SECOND THE MOTION
A SECOND. THOUGHT THAT- BELIEVE
THERE IS SOMEBODY TESTIFYING BY
PHONE. OPERATED WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON THE QUEUE THE SUPPORT
OF AB. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN.
DELICIOUS SUPPORT- AB FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN A PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. AT THE MOMENT.
OPERATOR
WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY. YES NOW
WE GO TO NINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR GOVERNOR
ABOUT THE SAN FRANCISCO FORTY
NINERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. FOR THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE ONE OF TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS THE FOR THE
MILLIONS OF MONEY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR GOING TO SUPPORT.
FIFTY ANYONE IN THE COMMUTER ON
AND SUPPORT. I SEE NON ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION VIA PHONE TO AB
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN OPERATOR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. IT WAS TO
COME IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE TIME.
BY THE TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU WITHOUT ANYONE
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM FOR HEARING ROOM. TO IT AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY. SENATE HEARING
ON BRING IT TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANNE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. WITHOUT A
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBERING THIS
BILL FOR A LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THIS AS WELL AND ANY
OTHER EVENTS WILL COME FORWARD
IN STATE OF CALIFORNIA BETTER
PREPARE SO WITH THAT I DO HAVE
AYE RECCO SECRETARY CAN CALL
THE ROLL. RODRIGUEZ HI
RODRIGUEZ I START DEL FIVE SIR
SO I GUARD CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
CALDERON. CALL JOHN I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER FIVE GREAT. BOARD
WITHOUT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS AND THE MOTION
IS A THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO WITH THAT MOVE ON TO
THE LAST ITEM FIVE NUMBER SIX
AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE WHICH IS
MINE NOW HAVE SWITCHED OVER TO.
VICE CHAIR SIR YOUR TOTAL TO
TAKE OVER WHILE I PRESENT THANK
YOU. DURING COME OVER HERE.
RIGHT WILL GIVE A COUPLE
MINUTES TO GET DOWN THERE. THIS
WILL BE AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. MR
RODRIGUEZ YOU'RE. READY TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU TO STRUCTURE
MEMBERS MEMBERS ALTHOUGH THIS
BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
OFFERS A CLEAR DIRECTIVE TO
EMSA TROOP CREATE A TASK FORCE
ON WHAT TIMES WE'RE ALL TOO
FAMILIAR WITH REPORTS OF
AMBULANCES ON THE CRUISE
WAITING FOR HOURS AND HOURS TO
OFFLOAD PATIENTS IN THE MERGING
DEPARTMENTS. AS I CONTINUE WORK
WITH EMS PROVIDERS ON THIS BILL
TO SET SPECIFIC MILESTONE TO
SOLVE. AMPLIFICATION UPLOAD
THAT LAYS FOR SUPPORT IN THIS
BILL. AS WITH COVERT MOVING
FORWARD OF KNOW IF YOU'VE HEARD
STORIES OF PATIENTS. IN
GURNEY'S AN AMBULANCE DOORS
ARE. BACK OF AMBULANCES FOR UP
TO TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN HOURS.
CONCORD BACK TO MY EXPERIENCES
WORKING IN THE FIELD OWNED BY
HAVE. BAD YEARS OF FLU THAT I
MYSELF FOR WAITED IN THE ER FOR
UP TO TWELVE HOURS. ARE WAITING
FOR A BED IN A HOSPITAL SO WITH
THIS. RESPECT OUT FOR OUR VOTE.
AND WITHOUT ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS I BELIEVE
I DO HAVE SOMEBODY ON THE
PHONE. IN SUPPORT. RIGHT DO YOU
HAVE ANYBODY AS A WITNESS
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. I HAVE A MOTION BY A
YEAR CURRY. SECOND I'LL SECOND.
OKAY WEIDEMANN. YEAH OKAY
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT WE HAVE ANY
EYE WITNESS TESTIMONY THIS TIME
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MISTER OPERATED LIKE TO EXPRESS
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL AND
WE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. OVER
LINE. ONE ONE TWO ONE PRESS ONE
ZERO SECOND TIME. ALL THE HELP
THERE WE GO NINE ONE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AMY BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT I WILL
JUST MENTION THAT THE AMBULANCE
PATIENT OFFLOAD TIME OR WHAT WE
CALL WHILE TIME DELAYS. AFFECT
BOTH THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR IN DELAND THE OPERATORS
EQUALLY THERE WAS THAT AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY REPORT IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY- BETTENCOURT OF
LAID OUT THE FINDINGS OF THE-
WHAT TIME DELAYS. THEY'RE
LOOKING AT A RECOMMENDED TWENTY
MINUTES FOR WALL TIME AND AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
WERE IN THAT HOURS AND- WAIT
TIMES SO IF ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO ADDRESS THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE BEING A PART
OF THIS DISCUSSION AND THANK
COULD BE ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAREN
WELL. AS FOR YOUR ABOUT. THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER AND I. PEOPLE
JUST PART WHERE YOU JUST
EXPRESS. WHO YOU ARE WHAT YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS AND ALSO- WITH
A YEAR SUPPORTING THE MEASURE.
THE BILL. NEXT BIGGER JEAN.
SPEAK ON THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE
ARE NO LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THEN WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM DO WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
HEARING ROOM IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL. SUPPORTED THE BILL. DOES
NOT APPEAR THAT THERE ARE ANY.
SO AT THIS POINT ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. ON THE
LINES. SPEAKING OPPOSITION MAY
ALSO PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO THANK
YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. R.
ITEM WILL BRING IT BACK TO A
HEARING ROOM TO- TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY REMOTE TESTIMONY.
ANYBODY IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THEY'RE BEING NINE WELL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MR
RODRIGUEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AS PROGRESS FOR ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT- SO WE WILL GO AHEAD
IN- CALL THE ROLL AND- CHAIR
RICE CHAIR RECOMMENDS AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS. THE FACT OF HI
CERTA I. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I CALDERON
CALDERON I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
I GREAT. BOARD REWARD FIVE
THAT'S THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
FOR PRE. I'M A MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I DO ALSO I. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING HIS ENERGETIC
FORWARD. WELL FAMILIAR WITH THE
ISSUE. OF A HOLDING UP THE WALL
IN THE ER IT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR A LONG TIME IT'S GREAT THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN THE STEPS TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. COOL YEAH.
SO WITH THAT I BELIEVE WE GOT
ALL THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY BUT I KNOW WE HAVE TO
MISS YOU MEMBERS FOR SOME OF
THE BILL FROM THE BEGINNING SO
A SECRETARY JUST TWO MEN ROLE
FILE ITEM SO THE START WE'RE.
I'LL START WITH THE- CONSENT
CALENDAR SECRETARY CAN CALL THE
ROLL ON THE MISSING MEMBERS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CALL JOHN.
CALDERON I GALLAGHER- GALLAGHER
EYED GRAY. AND WITH THAT WE'LL
GO ON FILE ITEM. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SECTOR CALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS AB ONE
EIGHTEEN. KAMLAGER FORD ALL
LORD I. FOR THE- THAT'S ONE
FIVE NUMBER TWO A BEFORE
EIGHTEEN VALIDATORS. ALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER I'D BOARD BOARD I'D.
THERE WITH THE- MOVED FROM
NUMBER THREE AB EIGHT OH FIVE
MAIENSCHEIN SECRETARY CALLED
MISSING MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I BOARD. BOARD I'D.
OKAY WITH THAT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR A. B. FOURTEEN OH THREE
LEVINE GREAT. FORD I. OKAY WITH
THAT MOVE ON TO PHAM NUMBER
FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS GABRIEL GRAY. FORD FORD
I. IN WITH THAT WITH- BLOSSOM
NUMBER SIX A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
NINE CALL THE MISSION MEMBERS
FOR A. FOR I WOULD CALL PHONE
NUMBER SIX A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
NINE GREAT. OKAY I THEY WITH
THAT WE'LL GO BACK TO THE FIRST
MONTH OF ANY MISSED MEMBERS-
PHONE NUMBER ONE AB ONE
EIGHTEEN SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. WE GOT A WELL FROM A
NUMBER TO AB FOURTEEN- PHONE
NUMBER THREE AB IT'LL FIVE OR
PRESENT. ABOUT A PHONE NUMBER
FOR A BI FORTINO THREE MISSING
MEMBERS. I HOW ABOUT NUMBER
FOUR NUMBER FIVE AB FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN GABRIEL OF THE MACHINE
MEMBERS. GREAT I. IN WITHOUT-
DO WE HAVE A CONCERN
COUNTERACTING GEIGER FOR
CONCERT CALENDAR. YEAH THAT
OKAY SO WITH THAT I BELIEVE
THAT EVERYBODY. SO WITH THAT
SAID THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU ALL. THANK YOU.